le gouvernement français adoptaient
tierces lierre au conseil des ministres
un projet de loi autorisant la publicité
sur les préservatifs moyens de
prévention contre les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles et notamment
le sida
une campagne publicitaire est déjà prête
avant la discussion le mois prochain de
ce projet de loi on veut changer les
mentalités
mais dans la pub les habitudes ont la
vie dure vous allez le voir et ce sont
les femmes qui ont la charge des
préservatifs reportage du sis aux boules
yves barbe voilà la liste du shampoing
doux du maquillage waterproof une crème
solaire protectrice et les une crème
solaire très hydratante des préservatifs
ces préservatifs oui des préservatifs
tiens regarde trois amis qui partent en
vacances indispensable emporté les
préservatifs
s'il a des exemples présentés dans ses
clips réalisés par l'association aides
qui lutte contre le sida pour la
première fois on y montre des
préservatifs et on y parle éducation
sexuelle
jusqu'ici la publicité pour les
préservatifs étaient interdites car
assimilé à la propagande anti nataliste
aujourd'hui la prévention est la seule
arme contre les maladies sexuellement
transmissibles et le sida
l'information du public sur les
préservatifs était devenu nécessaire les
informer ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on leur dira mesdemoiselles mesdames
ayez tout un préservatif dans votre sac
car la proche
femmes hommes les suédois nous l'ont
bien fait comprendre est beaucoup plus
facile
la jeune fille le proposera un
préservatif à son partenaire masculin
au lieu que ce soit quelque fois le
partenaire masculin qu'il impose et par
ce système là et bien les jeux de
l'amour seront même peut-être plus
agréable dans certaines et certains pas
et en plus de ça se la jouent un rôle
non négligeable dans la prévention
contre les mst
donc voyez vous à mon avis propagande
tous azimuts à tous les niveaux et
surtout ne pas se contenter de mettre
des préservatifs à disposition des gens
sans en même temps leur distribuer des
brochures de redistribuer même des
informations assez cru en montrant
comment les mettre exactement ce que
vous faites est soit loi et nous aurons
deux
mais la publicité sera t elle suffisante
pour que la france comble son retard en
matière d'utilisation des préservatifs
on les dit peu solide et peu agréable
employés ils n'ont pas bonne réputation
chez nous aujourd'hui seuls 5 % des
couples les utilise toute une campagne
d'information reste à mettre en place
pour convaincre les français que les
préservatifs ce n'est pas ringard et
qu'il est plus prudent de ne pas se
comporter comme des autruches